talking about
this is the moment Imran Khan was taken
into custody surrounded by a sea of
Rangers Pakistan's paramilitary force in
full riot gear
earlier guarded by his supporters Imran
Khan had arrived at Islamabad high court
for one of
127 court cases against him he says are
politically motivated
five moments later Security Forces
smashed windows at the court to gain
entry to take him into custody of
bemused Imran Khan looking on as the
drama unfolded Imran Khan had predicted
this as he set off for court Mira
Pakistan
this is my Pakistan it's not yours it's
our military you can't just shut our
mouths when we criticize you if there's
a warrant for my arrest simply hand it
to me and my lawyers and I'll hand
myself in I'm ready to go to jail
heart of this is
Imran Khan and Pakistan's powerful
military he's accused them of
orchestrating a series of moves against
him his ouster in a no-confidence motion
in April last year and an attempted
assassination a few months ago in March
his party members are raising concerns
for his safety longer he's in there we
feel that he'll be assassinated and we
feel that he'll be killed in their or
badly torture
the cricketer turned politicians party
there again saf the party for justice is
calling for people to shut down Pakistan
these are scenes we have never witnessed
before in Pakistan civilians attacking a
military base women leading the way for
protesters
[Applause]
a military rarely questioned with
unparalleled power this is the Pakistan
Army's General headquarters
hundreds Gathering outside the Army
Corps Commander's house in Lahore some
breaking in
there has been civilian governance for
15 years now but there are always fears
of a coup the last thing the country
needs is for a dictatorship to come for
elections not to be held because with
the difficult economic situation what
you need is a government that has been
elected by the people so they can take
hard decisions
Imran Khan an icon of Pakistan has
pitted himself and his supporters
against the most powerful institution of
Pakistan Simon Mawson Sky News